est ce que vous êtes pour le mariage des
prêtres entre oui c'est cela seul façon
aux neuf d'emmener quelqu'un à l'automne
et quand on va voir ce qu'en pensent les
gens dans la rue lebas pichot sinon je
comprends pas je vois je vois pas
pourquoi ils peuvent l'être les juifs le
sont les protestants leçon je vois pas
pourquoi compris vrai un homme du désir
d'aimer de la chair et autres choses qui
peuvent approfondir le désir de vivre à
deux
et encore mieux en communion quoi donc
vous êtes pour le mariage des prêtres
entre bien c'est entre eux le mariage ne
prétend t non alors là l'eau non bravo
vous pensez qu'il est mieux qu'il
continue de se cacher que les prêtres se
fâche se cache cache leur amour moi je
préfère oui si je connaissais un prêt
qui ont qui était un peu plus rapprochée
que les autres mais j'avais quoi j'avais
12 ans et tripoter un petit peu par un
prêtre d'éléments ouais ouais mais bon
c'est on est wayne quoique
ouais mais non mais c'est contradictoire
a vocation à 10 ans de mariage ils cette
époque avec lui ah non non c'était comme
un père j'ai pas seulement mais non on
va faire un petit peu assez ce que tu
peux tu pour aucun mariage quels qu'ils
soient
pourquoi il faut vivre libres pensez
donc vous êtes pour l'union libre en ce
qui concerne les prêtres ah oui chacun
fait ce qui lui plaît
lorsqu ils s'aiment aux écoutes femme
raconte les histoires ne sais quoi bon
comment le mariage des prêtres entre eux
oh my home non mon seigneur qui en pince
pour un autre monseigneur même vous avez
déjà eu une relation une relation
sexuelle avec un prêtre et les soeurs
entre l appareil pareil par habib sy les
écuries et les soeurs où va sa défense
c'est ça devait se faire sur vente dans
tout mais les curés les bergers
allemands est moins sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu